hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play when life
has no living this list when death has
no life when I forgot name the damn
thing when life has nothing to live for
anyway it's a very sad depressing title
but anyway we just went into the machine
room after solving that incredibly hard
Buzzle gosh I need to get the machine
running the gate will not open without
it
okay whatever you say buddy what have
you say pal friend oh okay your machine
running as soon as I break your face
open okay so there's got to be some in
here I don't even see a lever button or
anything I can't see anything to get
this thing started so uh-oh
here in front of my face Kurt chunk good
whoa say what say what I need to get out
of this place or something is wrong I
need to fix a machine
say what okay this pipe burst what about
that is there something I should concern
myself with I don't seem to I need to
cover that leak with something how about
your ugly face how about my ugly face
okay how about a one-book haha
really I didn't work it didn't work
enough how about a box
no box no good enough box not good
enough there's got to be like a oh hello
found a crowbar I almost miss that
nothing has Explorer so I can't I can't
see anything
it's gotta be like how about a brick
brick sounds like something that would
definitely cover a leak
oh so heavy not so big oh so big all
right so that's apparently not working
or maybe the box got stuck and now okay
the box good how about you
okay what happened to my I can't click
on that now stuff nah as soon as I put
something on there I can't move it so
let's just keep piling stuff on here
nope nevermind I didn't work cupboard
all right leak totally covered damn it
you know what screw it
get off of there get off there you damn
book you're damn frickin book I want to
get you off there get off there now the
book I don't even know why this is doing
anything but get off of there you're
obviously not good enough you're not
good enough apparently nothing's good
enough
what the hell well this is stupid
this is Ripley dumb my suppose I put
something specific there but now well
whatever maybe there's something over
here that I can use with the crowbar and
there yeah there's by something in here
that I could have used for it that I was
stupid and I put a frickin book on it
sheet metal would cover the leak maybe
okay so a book was wrong look who's very
wrong flop haha
didn't even work look a stupid I never
find this game risky that's weird
I need a key for the exit those martim i
don't even know the full length of my
own house alright good enough Kurt Young
lift it up Thank You upside-down cross
got key all right let's get out of here
to the exit of foreverness wait no
that's death the exit of forever is
death how profound am i I'm so possum
with my clothes
freedom is overrated ha yeah self-five
no thank you
I don't want to be here I know this room
this area is a bad area it's got bad
vibe man who's Bobby who da be there
there's the exit
yeah come on right behind it I know I
wrong decisions can sometimes be deadly
no kidding I knew it I knew I knew
building under the ground I wonder who
the former owner really want really
that's what you wonder after falling
from a demon attack about a hundred feet
you wonder who wonder who the owner
would know you think ah ah ah that's
what you think
whatever you do do not look at them they
have senses that human don't have if you
go no more I hid it in my library I
didn't make any sense whatever I don't
care you know what I don't care I don't
care anymore okay
blood on the walls blood on the floor
blood that's a lot of blood man like
I've said before your your blood trails
they aren't they aren't realistic
they're not there's not that that's just
not that much blood hi
okay hiding yes please and thank you go
run get all the way barrel Dow it thank
you you didn't hear a thing cuz you're
so stupid you're so stupid
I'm gonna fall this inhumanly long trail
of blood Oh someone got beaned up
against that oh look at that
it's the remainder hi how are you I am
fine recently okay
I'm gonna use this as a hiding spot I
know that hi are you there is how you
Billy are you practicing your piano
Romeo Romeo oh why did I blow that out
new candle
you got enough another upside-down cross
and a hidey hole there like a key or
something there it is okay I can't
really ah hi bye I don't know
how you doing sorry wait I hear piano
over there if that's not Billy there's
another
door with blood trail it doesn't work
like this there was another door over
here just trying to conserve maybe right
here ah yes yes indeedy-do what was that
what okay all right come one by me
nobody's mine I got you belly got a
Crouch arrived home free nothing to
worry about there oh hell yeah
yeah that's disgusting everything is
disgusting to the slaughter cage
what was that written on the door did I
know that beforehand why I had to buy
just this house why you had to buy just
this house you mean you could have
bought more come on whoo hello hi there
see you're just hanging out good good
one markiplier so funny that's why
you're so funny
hello skulls impaled on spikes there
something behind here there seems to be
some strange stack of boxes with the
door behind it wonderful
why would someone barricade this floor
good good good advice good advice and
sound advice right there
alrighty then my crowbar break nope I
still got it
alright what's down this really rather
what is that what is that times row box
I thought what was that I saw something
I saw something what was it what was it
ah crap uh-uh
got the handle stupid oh no oh no
now that demos man I'm not here I'm not
here what are you talking about I'm not
here I never was here I like you good
Helen you die that's right go the wrong
way down the hallway I'm over there
totally
yeah he's so stupid it's so stupid
look at stupid gun that way what I'm
obviously over here oh you're so dumb
I'm so smart on another cell 5 I think
so yeah
what is that strange sound I hear
there's a Carius precariousness with
this environment what's that where does
that go does that leave the other way
into this area I think I'm like ah ha ha
ha
I have you beaten now you cannot fool me
yeah well someone is obviously jumping
very carelessly on this stairs gotta be
very careful I know from personal
experience I've jumped down many the
staircase and you see I'm perfectly fine
perfectly normal
I'm supposed to go up not down but I
think there's not other war this was on
the base with the whole time where am I
I believe this is some sort of plane of
hell may be perfectly normal thing to
have just down here right alright then
let's just have a nice set down and talk
this over the door won't open there is
nothing else here right just this door
that won't
how about i bash it down how about a
crowbar
nope that door is not gonna open else as
a page
I made this liquid to feed my ability to
interpret better the Satanic Bible I
realize one thing too late I will be
gone so soon too soon
this liquid causes a powerful boobies to
me I can hear the wind coming from the
netherworld first I thought that I start
to see my own but then the Valkyries
came out of body experience oh oh
not oh huh there's boobies to me Oh
wanna I don't wanna drink it you can't
make me oh my god I'm drinking it glug
glug glug glug okay then sooo what why
did I drink that liquid I don't know you
did it oh hi oh never I've been I've
been more happy to see this well alright
then what where am I now
hello I'm outside well this is perfectly
strange and all but I still don't have
any answers uh-oh whoa no whoa no oh no
oh no you do not oh no you do not
you faceless bastard I refuse all right
coming coming boom double figure defence
ha made you think twice about that one
Yeah right get back run off you cannot
conquer this I am too pro
hey it worked
alright then yeah you better run you
better up oh you want another taste all
us who can't be yeah that's right that
turn around
it's okay boys it's working hey doesn't
know they're likes of who only one only
wow I'm stood haha oh boy do not be
afraid of that who may damage your body
but rather fear him who can take your
soul you got his buddy alright Frank of
potions what was that was that just a
dream yes
no he said something about boobies and
now everything is smashed up against
that door what is going on here
I do not know i shy it's always the
double finger defense it's not that
single finger I got cocky on that one
that was my fault I got cocky but I'm
actually all out of time for now so
thank you all so much for watching
and as always
ah
China
haha
ah
ma shorter
Oh
god